pelosi tried to sabotage green new deal
rollout over fears of aoc new book this
is a fox news story house speaker nancy
pelosi tried to sabotage to roll out a
representative
alexander ocasio-cortez green new deal
in 2019 because she was anxious about
the new congresswoman's
notoriety becoming actual power
according to a new book about the
insider democratic politics obtained by
fox news in february 2019 pelosi called
massachusetts
senator ed markey the night before he
was scheduled to help roll out the green
new deal she asked him to hold off she
wanted more substantive policy
the politics weren't good right then
don't give the platform to ocasio-cortez
she urged anxious about the new
congresswoman notoriety become an actual
power edward isaac dover
rights in battle for the soul inside the
democrats campaign to defeat trump
the green noodle rollout formally
outlined the proposal in congress for
the first time
and would mark a start on the path
towards what aoc called a wartime level
just economic mobilization plan to get
to 100 renewable
energy cost estimates for the sprawling
proposal
ranging to the trillions dover's book
will be published on tuesday so
aoc was concerned about i'm sorry pelosi
was concerned about aoc creating
momentum yeah you know she's old school
man uh this is my house
speaker of the house if i finally found
one reason to like nancy pelosi you know
she's gonna be
laying the hammer down there that book
has got so many explosive findings in it
that's the book that has
obama ripping trump obama swearing at
the media obama's got a pretty filthy
mouth
if you read this book you're gonna be
blown away how much that guy swears
that's what trump will do to obama
get him person oh well well this is just
a classic case of reality versus
fantasyland
as say what you want to about nancy
pelosi she's been doing this for 40
years at least she's living in reality
where aoc is just
fantasy land over here with her trillion
dollar green no deal
and this is nervous nancy basically
saying pump the brakes on aoc
uh that woke cancel culture leftist
movement on the left of the democratic
party
they don't exactly uh have a lot of
substance to their numbers i don't think
uh
alexandria ocasio-cortez has been in
power what two
three years now this is her second term
right now
and uh i don't think she understands how
budgeting works and that's the problem
that she's going to face
but she does have upside if she actually
learns math she's a dangerous
political figure oh my let me ask you a
couple questions who's more attractive
him more
hero pelosi i mean come on it's not even
a question okay all right who's got a
bigger following on twitter
it's not even a comparison seven million
aoc
it just so you know i said pelosi is
what seven million aoc is at
uh uh uh come on aoc where are you at
aoc is at 12.7 million okay who's better
at rallying aoc or pelosi
aoc aoc who who's who understands
understand social media better aoc or
pelosi
who who's more marketable long-term aoc
or pelosi
who's a better salesperson aoc or pelosi
who's
you want to keep going like you talked
about with china and india you attack
people who are threatening you pelosi is
clearly threatened by aoe
exactly and she is more marketable
i don't agree with her policies but she
is a much better politician than
pelosi although pelosi is a dirtier
politician behind closed doors because
she's been around longer
so she's got the entire playbook of
seven whatever 50 years she's been into
politics
she knows all the playbooks versus new
schools i still think it was she's going
to end up beating her long term if you
ask me oh yeah i think nancy is retiring
after this
it's a clearly long term yes yes got the
upside
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye